okay do you guys know what a high value
man is
um
i'm just gonna say no
not based on the
public definition
of what it is so i'd like to know okay
so it's like a coin that kevin samuels
he didn't make up but he made popular
so basically a high value man is a guy
that makes 10k per month and he must
have done this for three to five years
other men have to accept him as high
value he has a network of high value men
he has a linkedin level of visibility
and he's useful to others in the group
okay
so
um
a common thing in the manosphere was
that high value men have the right to
cheat
um
i would say that high value men are far
and few in between so it's a small
percentile of men
um
they have the capability to cheat more
because of their financial position and
position of power
but if they should do that that's a
that's an ethical thing morality thing
i would say they shouldn't i know they
shouldn't but they probably do
and they get away with it because they
have money yeah and i think women who
are with them are willing to accept it
because of the financial benefits and
the lifestyle so without the lifestyle
and the benefits on her side she
wouldn't accept that
so yeah
okay that's the rationale for me so if
you guys got twenty thousand dollars a
month would you look the other way when
it came to cheating
20 000 he's not he's not in love with
her it's just it's just some strange
here and there
would you look the other way twenty
thousand tax-free yeah 20 pounds 20k you
know yeah yeah yeah 20k a month
what so you can go to cheap
first of all no
you can't i can't no you can't
just because i know i can live off of
less than 20 000 a month
and i think because of the family that i
come from i was taught that it's not
about materialism it's about honoring
yourself
respecting yourself and if a man is with
you and he doesn't feel that he has that
respect for you even though he's saying
oh you know it's just a thing
in myself there's something inside of me
that just wouldn't allow that to go down
okay so you wouldn't you would i would
but i have boundaries what's the
boundaries um i need to understand
everybody needs to be tested first of
all okay this sounds crazy and yeah i'm
a bit crazy but
no it's not i don't think that's crazy
everybody needs to be tested
oh like for st okay that's reasonable
yeah
um
as long as it's not a constant thing
yeah if i have what i also need sexually
and also
if there's no
limits on what i can do with the money
if that makes sense yeah like it's it's
yours yeah yeah yeah so
i mean i would so you can save it
yeah i can save it
i can do whatever the hell i want with
it then yeah
but at the same time saving for exit
if it was a situation but then i say
that
if this was me maybe like three years
ago
these would have been
my limits and what i would have said to
do but maybe now
i wouldn't accept it just because of my
personal values and x y and z but yeah
okay
what what about you two months i was
thinking about it's like
you know there's a lot of people in
those situations but um
if you're gonna pay me to just be there
then why am i here i might as well just
no no you're the
you're the wife you see you're not just
there you're the mother of his kids your
name's on the house you get you get the
ring it's just a casual thing here and
there you know what culturally that
happens a lot so much so it's kind of
it's the ones i can say oh i'm kind of
used to that like you see a lot of women
that men are just out here got the sugar
babes got the you know the sugar babe of
the sugar babe so
i don't know mm-hmm no because
my thing is you're probably getting
cheated on for free yeah
because it happens like people get
cheated on 24 7 and then they don't even
get the benefits of the 20k
so i mean
but then doesn't that highlight that
you're kind of in the relationship for
the 20k then
are you in the relationship to be with
the man or the money that's that's the
question
a relationship com
encompasses a
a load of things whether it's money
love wealth status
um
what else character like there's many
things that
come into what a relationship is yeah um
like you're still the wife he still
loves you it's just it's just like men
men crave variety and he says look i
make a lot of money i love you you're
always going to be the main chick it's
just here and there i might step out
from time to time you'll never know
there'll never be any stds like yeah i
can't stop you yeah so if i can't stop
you but at least elise is saying it
lisa's like telling you show me the
money
you know
something yeah because it's a team
effort you can see as the relationship
as a business
you could be like okay yeah this is this
is what i am to you this is what you are
to me i can't stop you from doing what
you're doing
so
if you're going to give me an allowance
yeah for the headache yeah cool but you
have to one vital thing is you have to
be clean about it don't be messy don't
be i wouldn't get in court here and
there and all my friends can see you
doing this yeah but that's the thing
that's one thing you can't control what
the other women do
so you know if your mind is of high
value and then a woman decides to come
out and say boom i'm in america
even in that scenario you still have
women that kind of break that boundary
because they start to have feelings if
it's a consistency no not not for the
those girls are professionals
for the right amount of money those
those girls are used to sleeping with
those like that's all just
escorts only then but they're they're
high-end escorts yeah that's what a lot
of like rich guys do
they're they're beautiful they're
they're just they're clean yeah and and
you have to like make a certain amount
of money to like actually yeah yeah so
if you think about it it's in
the pop culture and hip-hop culture
already yeah i think about it like we'll
talk about this area about offset and
cardi
why would you cheat on cardi she is she
was a former stripper she's got the
stereotypical body right i can't
she's she's very loud and can be
obnoxious but you liked her for a reason
but yeah but guys like women for
aesthetic at times you can look at
someone and say you're attracted to them
and as you get to know their
personalities and the facets about them
you realize actually i don't really
i'm not feeling it why why should he be
faithful when she was a stripper
but the thing is
on the flip side he already took an l
because he wiped the stripper yeah
that's a whole element in itself oh for
sure but if well i mean
because men want to be with her like
let's not get it wrong like if you're a
stripper no but that's like a thing a
man a lot i'm not gonna say woman a lot
of men they fantasize about a life or a
type of thing but when it comes down to
it the real life scenario they're not
built for it a lot of men are not built
for that
but they they don't have they don't have
the resilience to be in a relationship
with a woman like cardi b where she
makes money yes she has a stripper
background she's loud she's not like a
quiet person who was a stripper she's
out there you know and
and the facets that make her her
stripper past part of her her current
present moment are still at the
forefront did you get what i mean so
not a lot of me no not a lot of men are
built for it
and i think in their minds it's like
having a threesome a lot of guys are
like yeah i want it when it comes down
to it can they do it though
the pressure is a lot i was going to say
that um
wow that went left yeah yeah no no no
but that's i've seen it like not on in
my life but on tv and stuff on those
programs they're like yeah that's my
dream and then when it comes down to it
they couldn't they could check it out
too much pressure
too much fresh shot i don't know i'm
still a virgin
same he's born again yeah i'm running
again
every week
i was going to say that i'm sorry
i feel like if offset did not cheat on
cardio
she wouldn't make certain music which
wouldn't make her certain money
because even when summer walker came out
with her outward before she came out
with her album she encouraged her to do
the album
so that she would make money off it so
again it's like really if cardi b
met a guy who was that good guy that
would treat her right she wouldn't want
to be a stay-at-home wife she wouldn't
want to be
a
stay-at-home mom she wouldn't want to be
she'd she'd get bored and she'd
if beyonce never got cheated she
wouldn't have a lot of the music yeah
got cheated on sorry if beyonce would
have never gotten cheated on she
wouldn't have a chunk of the music that
she has yeah because lemonade was huge
lemonade i think i think someone like
cardi's forever for the streets to be
honest like
but that's her persona and that's who
she is
offset signed up for that when he
married her yeah just like if you look
at drake having a child with that young
lady
it it's in a man's mind it's her fantasy
really a lot of men i don't think he was
trying to have a kid with her i know but
he he took it there and the fact that
he's on an accident
she probably she probably i i think she
probably did something we already know
condoms out of the trash now
drake is like never again i'll never
uh
because cheating makes you more
attracted to a guy
does it really yes yes yes i mean how
many how many girls do you know that
they get cheated on they keep going back
and you're like
and how many of you have ever taken back
a cheater no no it's it's pre-selection
so we can't undo our biology
so
when a guy can get multiple women
we find it attractive it's like what's
worse you got your guy cheated on you or
he tried to cheat and he got rejected
i don't know i have that mentality of
like okay if you go cheat
just be careful one day i'll just
oh if i do it you're going to feel it
basically so you
it's a weird like well why would you
cheat
why would you cheat it lowers your value
like a little your body count lowers
your value as a girl so if you cheat
it's just like showing you're less
valuable
so like how i don't understand what
girls like cheap that's what do you
think about it because
in in the sexual marketplace guys they
want a woman with a lowest a lower body
count they say that but then also too
you want to go with experience so
for fun for fun they don't want to wife
them they don't put rings on their
finger and if yeah unless you're cardi b
so but things are changing women are
evolving so
but are they but are they evolving
but women are also women are also less
married
so women are getting less rings than
ever
what do you mean by women
it's evolving what do you mean
we are
noticing things from the past more than
ever and we're trying to let's say push
the boundaries of it so being more
self-aware
yeah we'll be more self-aware um more
conscious of our relationships our
values more our
morals and stuff like that
so
for instance in the western culture we
are more modern than
anyone else in the third world
so there are a lot of freedom on our
side we can work
as much as we want we can even do jobs
like construction plumbing all those
kind of things now
than probably like 20 years ago 20 30
years ago so what does that have to do
with us
like what does that have to do with the
conversation what are you doing so what
i'm trying to say is like you're
you're not seeing certain things oh
that's going to take away from my value
it's oh okay that's my experience that's
well it can be it can be your experience
but when you survey men and men say we
prefer women that have slept with less
people like you don't get to tell men
what they value like men value what they
value there's a man right here ish you
prefer a woman to make a wife that's got
a high body count a low body count low
i prefer one with a low body cat if i'm
going to wether but women
you want a mammoth sexual experience
question so we're talking about women
and women's body count making them less
valuable yeah
so why is it accepted when men have
such a high body count
because women are attracted to it
it's not it's not about it's not about
being accepted it's about
women deal with it so women want the
guys that have slept with more people
drake they don't they're not asking
drake what his body count is they don't
care but that's what i'm saying and why
i don't know ask the women we pick him
if we're in a situation whereby
um women are devalued for having high
body counts
my issue is not a really issue but the
question i'm querying is like why is it
acceptable like why is it
why is it normal why is it normalized
because it is because men and women are
different
so so biologically women liked a guy
that could get multiple women because
that that takes that's a sign that he
could take care of them i mean
historically
um there was 8 000 years ago there was
17
women reproduced for every one man
so that's like part of history where men
they had to ensure paternity so if you
were ho you're thought around they don't
know if they're giving you a kid that's
yours
so they're biologically
pre-predispositioned to be like
disgusted by that and so it's more like
supply and demand
that's what the sexual marketplace is
it's not people telling them what to
like it's just what people like the same
way men are attracted to like thinner
women have you noticed that on that on
the mori show there's no women on there
being brought on to see who the child is
yeah because it came out yeah because it
came exactly because that's what i was
saying because
like the chil we know children come from
women where if a woman's got multiple
penises inside of her as a guy you don't
know who but we always know who the
mummy is right we always know who mom is
right and but we never sometimes know
who dad is which is why we gotta do
paternity tests and et cetera et cetera
so
um yeah women
prefer men
to be
that guy who can sling it around and
then whereas guys don't prefer women to
be that woman that's things around